[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ومرحبا المشاهدين
الولايات المتحده على الجزائر ضمن قائمه
المراقبه للدول التي تمارس انتهاكات
الجسيمه للحوريات الدينيه او تتسامح معها
من الجزائر العاصمه الدكتور اسماعيل باشا
استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
بجامعه الجزائر اهلا بك مرحبا شكرا جزيلا
لك على تربيت هذه الدعوه مرحبا دكتور
الترحيب بك مرحبا
من واشنطن السيد بشار جرار الكاتب وعوده
الحزب الجمهوري الامريكي
ومرحبا شكرا جزيلا لك ايضا
صديقي العزيز مرحبا مرحبا
في بيان وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطونيو
بلينكن نقرا اضع الجزائر وجمهوريه افريقيا
الوسطى وجزر القمر وفيتنام على قائمه
المراقبه الخاصه لمشاركتها في الانتهاكات
الجسيمه للحريه الدينيه او التسامح مع
وسؤال ما تعليقكم على الابقاء على الجزائر
في هذه القائمه وهل تمت فعلا اليوم ما
يبرر ذلك السؤال الاول الدكتور اسماعيل
دبش استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه بجامعه الجزائر مرحبا من جديد
استاذ حكيم تحيه اليك وتحيه لمشاهدين
التوقيت
المعتقد الامريكي الحالي هو الذي يفسر
السبب الان الولايات المتحده نعرفها كل ما
يكون هناك
عدم انسجام مع توجهاتها الدوليه ومصالحها
ربما الاستراتيجيه التي تراها
فتوظف
طروحات مثل البعد الديني الديمقراطي حقوق
الانسان غير هذه الوصول للضغط على الانظمه
الحكم التي التي ذلك طبعا لا اعتقد انها
تختلف معي متحده حول حقوق الانسان
دائما
لها سياسه خاصه بها مستقله عن الضغوطات
الدوليه وتحاول ان توازن بين مصالحها
الوطنيه
الوضع الدولي ككل لان كل مره يكون هناك
مضايقات ونرجع للتسعينيات عند مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والدول الاوروبيه
اتهموا الجزائر بانها لم تكون تحالف
الارهاب وفي النهايه
ظهر بان الجزائر كانت النظام السياسي في
الجزائر والمنظومه الحكم كانت تحارب في
الارهاب بعد ما حدث في احداث سبتمبرز انه
وعد اذا انا اعتقادي موضوع التضييق هذه
على الحريات غير وارد في الجزائر واعطيك
الدليل ان الثوره الجزائريه انطلقت من ربه
50 سنه 60 وشارك فيها اليهود ومسيحيين
وعندها شوارع باسمهم وعندنا همم
اماكن تحريم مسميين مثل مثل ساحه عوده ولا
شولي وغيرها اذا لا يوجد هناك تطرف في
المنظور الى الاديان بل هناك فقط توظيف
سياسي من قيمه خارجيه تريد ان تما ان تحقق
اهداف السياسيه واغراض على حساب على حساب
التصور المحلي للدوله الوطنيه
خلال دقائق هذه الانتقادات اذا للجزائر في
مجال الحريات الدينيه مردود عليها يقول
الضيف يا دكتور اسماعيل السيد باشا الحزب
الجمهوري الامريكي قائمه المراقبه تاتي في
مرتبه ثانيه من القائمه السوداء همم ما
تعليقك انت على هذا القرار الذي اتخذته
الخارجيه الامريكيه وهل فعلا له ما يبرره
همم بشان همم الحريات الدينيه
للحريات الدينيه او تسامح همم معها ك يقول
بلانكن في بيانه مرحبا من جديد
احييك واشكرك على الاستضافه الكريمه بعيه
الاخ الكريم من الجزائر واقول ان الانصاف
يقتضي القول اولا لان هذه التقارير او
البيانات هي مرتبطه بقرار سنويه يتم خلال
رصد عده ملفات منها تقرير متخصص في حقوق
الانسان تقرير متخصص في مكافحه الاتجار
بالبشر مثلا وتقرير متخصص في حريات
الدينيه هذا جهد مؤسسي تعمل عليه الخارجيه
الامريكيه وزاره
النظر من يحكم البيت الابيض جمهوري او
الديناصورات وهذا الجهد يا عزيزي يتبعوا
منهجيه اكاديميه محبط يقوم على شهادات
يقوم على مسح ميدان على الارض وليس بما
يصدر من بيانات
صحيح ان الملفات هذه مجرد ذكر اسم الجزائر
وجزر القمر مع الاحترام يعني الى كل الدول
التي
يستعرضها ويستعرض اوضاع التقرير هناك طبعا
فار كبير
المستوى لم يصل الى ان تكون الجزائر على
اللائحه السوداء ولكن موضوع الحريات
الدينيه هذا مفهوم هناك تعريف اكاديمي له
هناك مقاربات سياسيه كيف انت تضع معايير
همم
من السهل القياسي يعني وليس التنظير حولها
وتقول ان هذه الدوله تراعي حريات الدينيه
وتحترمها ام لا ان اخطانا الميزان بمنتهى
الحزم ستجد ان شقى اوسط كله جميع دول
الشرق الاوسط لا حريه الدينيه بالمفهوم
الغربي يعني حتى اسرائيل التي تعتبر بنسبه
للغرب الديمقراطيه حقيقيه
مجرد ان تعرف ناسها بانها الدوله العبريه
هي تبتعد عن مفهوم الحياه الدنيا وتقول هي
وغيرها بانها لا تحارب الاديان المشكله
ليست بتسميه شوارع
بالميادين او كيف تقرا التاريخ امم
اساسي هل يستطيع اي انسان ان يعلن انه
اتخذ قرار بتغيير دينه دون ان طيب بصرف
النظر هذا لا ينطبق فقط على الاحمديين ولا
يلتقبق على المسيحيين الذين اشار البيان
بشكل خاص الى اوضاعهم هناك مشكله هذه
الجزائر هذه بلاد القديس او قديسين ثاني
اكبر يعني منظر يدعم الكنيسه الكاثوليكيه
في العالم
فكيف تمنع الجزائري الحق سواء كان عربيا
او امازيغيا ان يقول في بيته انه امارس
حوريه العباده ولماذا يعتبر ذلك تفسيرا
وهذا النشاط غير محظور على طرف اخرى
اذا كان وهو اختبا هذه جمله اذا كان
المعيار ان الدين الدوله الاسلام نعم هي
تونس وحده التي قالت ان الدوله دوله
مواطنه ولا يوجد دين للدوله في هذه
العزيزي الكل سوا طيب
اعود اليك دكتور اسماعيل دردشه استاذ
العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه في
سياق ما ذهب اليه ضيفي بين لينكن صحيح لم
يتضمن تفاصيل عن اسباب البقاء على جزائر
على هذه القائمه قائمه المراقبه ولكن كما
قال ضيف يتحفظات لامريكيه موجوده عليها
قراءه في التقارير السنويه للخارجيه
الامريكيه من خلال ما يوصف بملاحقه بعض
الطوائف المذاهب التيارات الدينيه منع
التبشير بالمسيحيه اغلق لك غير ملخص الى
غير ذلك هل تتفق فيما ذهب اليه ضيفه
تحديدا في تقييم واقع الحريات الدينيه همم
في الجزائر بشكل محدث
استاذ اعطيني فرصه فقط
مع ولا تمنع اي ممارسه معتقد عندما يكون
الامر شخصي ولا يكون عمر بحمله عاريه
ثانيا تقمع الذي تمنع الذي لا ليس له صفه
القانونيه
الاحمديه او ما يسمى بالاحمديه ليسجلهم
كيف قانونيه وبالتالي هم خارج القانون اذا
نعتمر نحترم الدوله
الحزبيه والتعدديه الثقافيه والسياسيه
ولكن وفق القوانين بتاع الدوله الجزائريه
بمعنى انه ان المسيحي يمسكن ان يمارس
طقوسه الدينيه داخل الكنيسه ان اليهودي
يمارس طقوسه اليهود داخل المعبد اليهودي
ان المسلمين يمارس تقوده داخل المسجد حتى
المسلمين ممنوع عليه يصلي الجمعه في اماكن
ليست لها شروط الاسلاميه
الاول المبدا الثاني يا استاذ عندما الاخ
يتكلم عن ما يسمى بالاحمديه ومع عدد قليل
جدا وهم يقومون باشياء
استفزازيه اكثر منها لها علاقه بالاسلام
يعني انحراف وانا على الدين الاسلامي
وانحراف على ما على معتقدات على توجهات
المجتمع فداته داخل الجزائر لماذا
الاحمديه مثلا ولماذا اليوم الرايتسو
لماذا لماذا
كل انسان
[موسيقى]
تمضي ولا واحد يتكلم عليهم لماذا عندما
يطهى عند المسلمين في اسرائيل ولا واحد
يتكلم
يقول ان العمليه السياسيه فقط لا هو
الجزائر لو الدوله الجزائريه اتخذت قرار
مطلق وتحالف مطلق مع المنظور امريكي عسكري
الجنسيه وك
سوف سوف تصبح الجزائر من احسن الدول ولا
تحكم ولا تقمع
لالالالالا حريه اقول لك يا استاذ حكيم
علاقات الجزائريه الامريكيه علاقات
استراتيجيه والدائما تمر بهذه الظروف
وليست للمره الاولى ان نسمع مثل هذه حول
حقوق الانسان وحيده لكن هناك مساومه
سياسيه صوتيه لكن تبقى العلاقات الجزائريه
الامريكيه متوازنه
العلاقات
مع الجزائر
الامريكي كيف يتحدث عن الازدواجيه معايير
والمدافعون اليوم على الجزائر يقولون انه
تم سوء فهمني واقع الحقوق الدينيه في
الجزائر دي قوانين البلاد واستمرار في
تجاهل جهود الجزائر في هذا المجال من ذلك
حتى ما اشارت اليه قبل اعوام الخارجيه
الجزائريه همم من امر عام 2006 المحدد
لشروط ممارسه الديانات اخرى غير الاسلاميه
ما يعكس احترام الجزائر الكبير الديانات
السماويه والقول ليس لي ولكن لي الخارجيه
الجزائريه استفاده الجمعيات الدينيه من
دون تمييز في الجزائر من دعم مالي من
الدوله التي تقوم بالاعتناء باماكن
العباده وترميمها مطالبه هذا مذهب اليه
ضيف ايضا الاشخاص الراغبين في تطوير نشاط
في المجال الديني بان تكون لهم الصفه
والاهليه من السلطه الدينيه التابعين لها
دفاع ضيفي عن واقع الحريات الدينيه في
الجزائر هل اقنعك وهل همم الاداره
الامريكيه تاخذ بقاعين الاعتبار الجهود
التي قامت بها الجزائر في هذا السياق قبل
لا نتحدث عن الجانب والقراءه السياسيه وما
ذهب اليه ضيفه من ازدواجيه معير
اخي حكيم من الحكمه قبل ان نذهب الى موضوع
ازدواجيه المعايير ان نتفق على التعريف
ماذا نعني بالحريات الدينيه لاحظيه ليست
حريه حريات
وهل يجوز ان اختصر مئات الاديان في العالم
فقط في دين واحد او ثلاثه اديان مثلا
الديانات الابراهيميه المساله ليست ما
اومن القضيه انه لكم دينكم ولي دين هذا هو
المعيار
التي هي احسن لماذا تخاف لماذا تخاف ان
يقوم الاخر بنعم بالتفسير لو قام بالتفسير
العلمي اين المشكله
حجه
قوانين البلاد وبشكل همم طيب همم
فكرته واعود اليك
الكلام
لها اكثر من طريقه للتعبير من ضمنها ليس
فقط ان امارس حقي
اختيار الدين الذي اراه مناسبه او الطائفه
ولكن ايضا من حق العباده والحق العباده
هذا مضمون صحيح دون ان يعطل الاخرين مثلا
عندما يقوم المسلمون او اي دين كان ان
يقوم الصلاه في وسط الميدان العام او في
وسيله نقل هذا تعطيل وتجاوز على حقوق
الاخرين ولكن ان تقوم ببيتك بدعوه من تشاء
هذه مثلا القوانين انا اعلم ان كل الدول
العربيه لها مواقف متباينه في حدودتها
ولكنها في المقام الاول هي حريه حريه
التعبير ما المشكله ان تحتفل بعيد الميلاد
المجيد الكريسماس او تعتمد بعيد المولد
النبوي الشريف في بيتك وتدعو من تشاء ومن
هو اهم لديك اذا كنت فعلا تمارس حريه
التعبير بان تدعو جارك الى المعتقد الذي
تراه فيه الخير والفلاح لك والاخرين اذا
يجب انه يفرق
ما دمت تريد دوله مدنيه المانيه في نظام
دولي يتعامل فيه الدول والمؤسسات لا يجوز
ابدا منطق الاحتكار ان تقول انا احتكر هذا
هو الدين الصح وهذا هو الوسيله الوحيده
لتبشيري او الدعم الى الدين اختم بمثال
واحد عزيزي الان كلنا نتابع المونديال
الجانب الديني التعبوي الدعوي الذي تم في
الدوحه هل كان يمكن ان يتسامح مثلا
بالدوحه او في الجزائر او في اي دوله
عربيه لو كان هذا التبشير الان لدين اخر
يعني هل سيقبل ذلك
هل نتحدث عن حريه التعبير ام احتكار لما
نراه
هناكيه واوروبيه صارخه طيب طيب
ضيف يقرر بانه همم انه تم ازدواجيه معايير
ولك ان تعاقب ايضا عن ذهب اليه الدكتور
اسماعيل دبش ولكن الى اي مدى فعلا همم ثم
قراءه سياسيه لهذا القرار قرار الخارجيه
الامريكيه حتى تعود اليك من الجزائر
العاصمه دكتور اسماعيل دردش على ضوء
تحديدا التقاء وصف بانه تقارب جزائري روسي
في ظرف فيها استثنائيه هي ظهر فيها الحرب
على اوكرانيا الظرفيه الخشيه من تقويه اله
الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا وهي نفسها
دكتور دبش خشيه 17 نائبا اوروبيا وقعوا
رساله قبل ايام فقط موجهه الى رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه الى مفوض الشؤون
الخارجيه للتعبير عن القلق بشان ما وصف
بالدعم الجزائري لموسكو هل فعلا ثمه قراءه
سياسيه لهذا القرار همم من قبل وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انطونيو بنك
يبدوني ان الغرض صفه عامه والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بصفه خاصه يطبقون ما
قام به بوش سابقا معي او ضدي يجب ان يكون
معك او لا انت مو مصنف مع روسيا هذا
التفسير خاطئ للعمل سياسي والعمل
الديمراسي لاي دوله لها سياده وتريد
مستقله الجزائر لها علاقات استراتيجيه
بتوازن مع امريكا
النواب الامريكان والنواب الاوروبيين لم
يقوموا باداره الكوزي عندما ضرب
امريكا عندما
تدمير ليبيا والعراق وغيرها لماذا هذه
المعايير
انا اعتقادي ان ال- ال- اخي من زميلك الذي
يحترم وما همم لكن هناك فقط تباين
توافق بيني وبينه ولكن لا يعلنونها انني
لا لست ضد حر حريه المعتقد
والممارسه الشعائر لكن تكون في اطار قانون
مثل فرنسا فرنسا لا تسمح لاي ممارسه دينيه
يهوديه مسيحيه او مسلم الا في اطار قوانين
الفرنسيه نفس الشيء في امريكا لماذا
الجزائر ممنوع عليها ان لا تطبق ذلك وتسمح
باي تجمعه خارج القانون اذا انا اعتقادي
ان العمل الان هي ممارسه سياسي وضغوط
سياسيه للدوله التي مطلوب منها ان تساير
وخاصه الجزائر
لان الجزائر كان مضمونها ان توفر منافذ
للغاز همم واستراتيجيه والتعبئه اقليميه
للتوافق مع الغرب والدليل ان الغرب عند
وخاصه الولايات المتحده عندما لم تسير ان
الجزائر
يستفزون في السياسه الخارجيه في ملف الدفع
اسبانيا
ضد الجزائر في ما يتعلق بالسحر الغربيه
ينتفع ببعض الدول الاوروبيه لاتخان مواقف
ما يسمى بحقوق الانسان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الصحراء المغربيه وغير يعني هذا
المواضيع كل هذه الموازنات ومقاربات
سياسيه الجزائر سياسي حكيم تتعرفها جيدا
الجزائر سياسه تتخارجيا منذ استرجاع
السياده 260 لها سياسه عدم الميل لاي طرف
وعدم الدخول في التحالفات ولم تدخل في
يومنا في اي تحالف والان زيد بقول لك
الغرض الرساله الموجوده عند العالم العربي
والافريقي لم يفهمها فيه توجه حالي من طرف
الدول العربيه ودول افريقيا نتيجه هذه
التطرف الغربي والضغوطات غربيه للذهاب
خارج المنظومه الغربيه في السياسه
عن هذه الاستفزازات التقليديه انا اعتقادي
على الغرب
ان يغير من سياسه الاستفزازته الضغوط
ويتعاملوا معه هذه الدول باستقلاليه
باحترام زياده هذه والا سوف يخسرون
افريقيا والعالم العربي والعالم سوف يتجه
الى تعدد هي قطبيه تصبح فيها الدول ربما
في في الوقت القريب دول كثيره مهمشه في
افريقيا والعالم العربي وتصبح السعيد
والقوه الاكبر تيار اخره وتعدد القطبيه
والتي لا تقدم الى امريكا ولا اوروبا
وغيرهم من الدول التي تريد ان تمارس الضغط
على هذه الدول ومن ح- بحديثك عن الضغط همم
على كل ظرف فيها هي ظرفيه استثنائيه وتمت
همم جهود قد بعض المصادر لثاني الجزائر عن
استيراد الاسلحه الروسيه اخفف الميزانيه
الدفاع
الجزائريه التي تمت مضاعفاتها لحد من
استكمال برامج تطوير مختلفه في الاسلحه
خاصه الروسيه منها هذا يحلني لان تستكمل
حديثك سيد بشار جرار الكاتب والحزب
الجمهوري الامريكي لاي مدى تم قراءه
سياسيه ودبلوماسيه لقرار الاداره
الامريكيه وزاره وزاره
الديمقراطيه همم
بشان الجزائر هذا لساته ان كان الجمهوريون
كانوا سيختلفون في طريقه تعاطيهم في هذه
المرحله مع الجزائر ولكن حتى الصحافه
الجزائريه تسال سي جرار هل ما اذا كانت
هذه الخطوه خطوه لينك تحديدا تناقد
التحركات التي بداتها واشنطن في المده
الاخيره لتعزيز علاقاتها مع الجزائر في
طرفيه الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا من ذلك
حتى لقاءات السفيره الامريكيه مع كبار
المسؤولين في الدوله الجزائريه الخطوه
الامريكيه اليوم هل تعزز همم هذا المنحه
همم
تذهب في عكسه همم كيف تنقل انت ذلك
هذه الامور ببعضها لان قضيه هامه جدا
الجزائر في عين وفي صميم الاهتمام
الامريكي بتعاقب الحزبيه الاهتمام زياده
وبلغ مستوى متقدم جدا في عهد الرئيس
الاسبق برك حسين اوباما الاهتمام بالجزائر
بسببين الرئيسيه الاول
هو شريك قوي جدا في محاربه الارهاب في
محاربه الاتجار بالبشر وهذه مساله في صميم
واولويات السياسه الامريكيه التي يجب
عليها الحزبان وايضا في اولويات اوروبا
قضيه مكافحه الهجره غير الشرعيه ومكافحه
الارهاب المثل الاخرى القوه الاقتصاديه
الهائله وخاصه في مجال الطاقه قضيه ايضا
صندوق السيادي الجزائر عنوان كبير وفيه
اهتمام كبير جدا فلا اذيع سرا ان يكون
هناك نوع من النقاش حتى داخل المؤسسات
الامريكيه ستجد نوع من التباين مثلا بين
الخارجيه والدفاع لا يمكن ان تضحي اطلاقا
في شريك في حجم الجزائر واهميته ولكن
مساله الضغوط هي الوسيله التي اعادت ما
تنتج من البيت الابيض عبر ادوات من هذه
الادوات الخارجيه ومن ادوات الخارجيه هذه
التقرير حقوق الانسان العماله قضيه البشر
الحريات الى اخره فالمساله الان مرتبطه يا
عزيزي كيف يستطيع
الدبلوماسي الجزائر التعامل مع الدبلوماسي
الامريكي ويقول له لنتفق على اننا مختلفين
واعتقد ان النشاط الاعلامي النشط للسفاره
الامريكيه في الجزائر واضحه الرغبه في
الانفتاح على المجتمع الجزائري بكافه
اطيافه وهذه مساله مهمه جدا قضيه اوكرانيا
هذه مساله تبقى ظرفيه
العالم نعم يعني انطق تماما مع الاخ
الكريم من الجزائر العرب جميعا الان
يبحثون عن بشائر وهناك نعم كمال بلغ حد
الاستياء من قضيه اما معي او ضدي
روسي
بين الامريكيين والجزائريين حتى يكون هناك
على الاقل ارضيه من المصالح مشتركه بين
البلديه
للاجتماع مع جميع الحكمه توضيح الخطوات
الملموسه اللازمه للخروج من هذه القوائم
وكل شكرا جزيلا لكما على هذه الحلقه جزيل
الشكر من الجزائر العاصمه الدكتور اسماعيل
دبش استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه بجماعه الجزائر شكرا جزيلا لك وكل
شكرا جزيلا لك من واشنطن سيد بشار انا
كاتب عضو الحزب الجمهوري الامريكي كتما
معنا في فقرتي وجهه